we all know robert herjavic as the chill
guy sitting in the right corner in shark
tank in many episodes we hear robert
talk about his background in software
and his rough upbringing as an immigrant
i was born in croatia which was a
communist country when i was there
called yugoslavia we had dirt floors and
hay and no running water for a long time
but it's never made clear how he made
his fortune and what exactly he's doing
now super fans of the show are often
quick to argue that robert's chill
demeanor is just a facade and that in
reality robert is a rather passive
aggressive dude that never follows
through with his deals according to
forbes within the first seven seasons of
shark tank robert made 24 deals on air
but only 11 of these actually closed
this means that robert's closing rate
was only 45.8 percent which is the
lowest of all the sharks and nearly half
of mark's closing rate so who really is
robert herjavec and how did he get rich
in the first place
taking a look back robert's backstory
isn't just some sob story for tv
he really did have a pretty difficult
childhood growing up as he was born and
borrowed in croatia on september 14
1962. at the time this territory was
controlled by yugoslavia yugoslavia
wasn't as strict as some other red
countries but they were still communist
and they upheld its principles robert's
family was never big fans of these
ideologies and robert's father was
actually repeatedly jailed for talking
out against the regime
apparently it was common for him to get
drunk and go on rants about how bad the
system was despite their differing views
though the family put up with yugoslavia
up until robert was eight years old when
the family immigrated to halifax canada
when they arrived in canada the family
only had a suitcase filled with clothes
and twenty dollars so robert's father
instantly started looking for a job and
eventually found a job at a factory
earning 76 dollars per week it's not
clear if he was actually a janitor at
the factory but robert has mentioned
many times that his father used to mop
floors at a factory as for robert
despite these extremely hard
circumstances growing up he says that he
was never mad about his situation he
didn't even know how life was on the
other side of the world so he had
nothing to compare to once robert
started attending school in canada
though he started to complain a bit you
see robert didn't know any english and
many of his classmates would bully him
about it one day he came home and
complained to his mom about how mean all
his classmates were though his mother
comforted him his dad told him to stop
complaining and to have some pride and
encouraging himself ever since this
experience robert says that he got very
good at just putting his head down and
working through hardships and
unfortunately for robert there were many
more hardships to come robert would end
up attending new college at the
university of toronto and to graduate
with a degree in english literature and
political science in the meantime robert
took on many side jobs working minimum
wage to help his family financially he
took on roles as a waiter a newspaper
delivery man and a retail salesman
things didn't get much better after
college either as robert would struggle
to find a job and he would end up
stumbling into the film field he didn't
become an alias director or anything but
he was able to score some short-term
gigs for example he served as the third
assistant director for the movies cain
and abel and the return of billy jack he
was also a field producer for global tv
for the 1984 winter olympics while
robert enjoyed these opportunities none
of these provided him with a stable
income and he was still waiting tables
to make ends meet what roberts really
wanted was a job in the fast-growing
tech industry but no one would consider
him due to his lack of background and
experience instead of complaining though
robert looked for ways that he could
gain this knowledge and the easiest idea
that came to mind was offering to work
for free a company called logic quest
would eventually agree to this offer and
after working for six months for free at
logic quest while still waiting tables
robert would secure a full-time position
and finally break into the tech industry
despite working so hard to get that job
robert was only able to stick around for
a few years as he was let go in 1990 by
this point robert was fed up with trying
to prove himself to employers and
decided to start his own business he
says that he never had any large
ambitions of being a business owner at
the time starting a business seemed like
the only way to continue progressing in
his career and that's why he took the
plunge to this day robert is a massive
proponent of working at 9 to 5 and the
things that he'd probably still be
working a 9-5 if he wasn't fired anyway
robert started his first business with
warren avis who is the founder of avis
rentercar it's not clear what the duo's
business was called or even what they
did but the most important part of this
business was the experience with warren
warren became a sort of unofficial
mentor to robert and was pivotal in his
future businesses
one experience with warren that was
especially influential was a story about
hot dogs
one day warren told robert that his
approach to sales was terrible
warren compared robert's sale style to
that of a hot dog vendor
robert was desperately peddling as much
product as possible on a daily basis to
simply make ends meet like the hot dog
vendor but at the end of the day it
wasn't the hot dog vendor that made the
big money the person who made the big
money was the hotdog vendor's supplier
warren advised robert to be the supplier
and not the vendor and the story really
resonated with robert but this wasn't
very realistic for him at the time as he
was just trying to make enough money to
afford his monthly mortgage payments
once his business with warren grew to a
moderate-sized noah robert would sell
his take for 60 000 and focused on
starting a business where he could be
the supplier and that brings us into
brac systems
brac systems was focused on developing
internet security software similar to
mcafee and given that the internet was
just in its infancy at that point robert
was able to ride the wave up through the
1990s and the black systems would become
the largest internet security provider
in canada by the end of the decade
before he knew it he was getting
acquisition offers left and right and it
didn't take him long to secure a deal
with atnt canada for 30.2 million
dollars in 2 000. the deal was almost
finalized but it was up to robert to
choose if he wanted to cash out in stock
or cash all of his lawyers and business
buddies were telling him that taking the
stock was a no-brainer he could defer
taxes and make much more money long-term
but robert's father told him to take the
cash and robert would end up listening
to his father for nearly two years after
the acquisition robert says that he was
very triggered as att's talk just kept
going up as the dot-com bubble roared on
but as we now know the bubble would
burst and the dnt canada would end up
filing for bankruptcy protection now
atnd canada did end up surviving but i
think we'd agree that taking the cash
buyout was a way better path than going
through a bankruptcy objectively though
robert wouldn't have really been hurt
financially even if he took the stock as
he also had another business that was
booming right after he sold breck robert
joined a startup called ramp networks as
vice president ram networks also
provided internet security software but
unlike back systems ramp also provided
broadband access solutions like routers
robert didn't work at ram for too long
though as ramp would be bought by nokia
in january 2001 for 127 million dollars
i doubt robert owned very much of the
company given how long he worked there
but considering the magnitude of the
acquisition even just a few percent
works out to millions of dollars so
robert was easily a multi-millionaire if
not a deca millionaire and robert would
decide that it was time to retire his
wife was still working so robert became
a stay-at-home dad and focused on
raising their children robert says that
this felt wonderful at first he didn't
have to worry about money he could do
whatever he wanted and he was building
experiences with his children it seemed
like things couldn't get any better but
as his children started to go to school
and he was the only one at home it
didn't take him long to start wondering
wtf am i doing with my life after just
three years of retirement robert decided
that the retirement life simply wasn't
for him and that he far preferred
building businesses especially given
that he could now build them out of
passion as opposed to necessity and with
that robert founded the herzberg group
in 2003.
robert didn't bet the bank with the
herjavec group like elon musk though
instead he preferred to start the
company with just twenty thousand
dollars clearly he didn't want to go
broke again if the business failed which
is smart but really robert didn't have
much to worry about as the herds of a
group was another internet security
company and he was quite experienced in
this field by this point the herjavec
group initially specialized in email
anti-spam protection but they have since
expanded into all sorts of cyber
security services and their revenue has
closely followed in their first year of
business the herds of a group pulled in
four hundred thousand dollars in sales
which is already quite nice but by 2012
this number would explode to 125 million
dollars today the herdsonville group is
the largest internet security firm in
canada and frozen 223 million dollars
per year in revenue unlike his last
businesses though robert has no
intention of selling the herds of a
group he's looking to grow the company
into a multi-billion dollar company and
at this point it's just a matter of time
until he gets there according to google
robert is currently worth 200 million
dollars but i'm pretty sure that this
number is out of date i've seen google
display this number for at least five
years and i'm pretty sure that robert
hasn't been stagnant for five years
especially in today's market environment
so i think a more realistic estimate is
probably 300 to 500 million dollars if
not more so robert is well on his way to
becoming a billionaire but he's not in
any rush to get there either robert has
been enjoying the process and he's been
spending a lot of time on hobbies like
racing and shark tank in 2011 for
instance he won the rookie of the year
award at the ferrari challenge as for tv
robert made his tv debut in 2003 on
dragon's den and he has since become a
regular investor on shark tank as well
and that brings us into all of the shark
tank drama
one of the biggest critiques against
robert is that he's often passive
aggressive towards some of the other
sharks and especially mark there's
really no argument against this as often
times it's very clear and i think this
really stems from robert's insecurity of
not being wanted most entrepreneurs who
come onto shark tank want to make a deal
with mark or lori sometimes they want
diamond for clothing businesses but
basically no one comes in looking to
make a deal with kevin barbara or robert
which is a shame given that kevin and
robert are awesome sharks kevin chooses
to play into this persona by ironically
calling himself mr wonderful and
squeezing the other sharks meanwhile
barbara acts like nothing is going on
and that entrepreneurs love her i think
robert however is a bit triggered by
this and that this leads to his
occasional passive aggressiveness and as
for his close rate while it's true that
he has the lowest close rate on shark
tank it should be noted that the sample
size is rather small and the other
sharks except mark aren't much better
they all hover at about 50 50.
also something else to keep in mind is
that the low number may be the
entrepreneur's fault as well
we know that most entrepreneurs
gravitate towards mark and lori so maybe
the problem is that robert just ends up
with lower quality entrepreneurs
as for mark's exceptionally high closing
rate i suspect that this is just an ego
play i bet that he likely feels 50 50
about many of his deals as well but he
ends up following through anyway just
because he can mark cares more about
keeping his word and following through
then losing half a million dollars and
that's completely fine given that he's
worth four times more than the rest of
the regular sharks combined also it's
not like robert hasn't invested a large
amount to himself as of 2019 robert
committed to investing a total of 16
million on shark tank and even if only
half of those deals closed that's nearly
10 million dollars which is probably a
significant amount if not a majority of
robert's liquid wealth and at the end of
the day i think roberts is at best shark
tank is not a business show that's on tv
it's a tv show that happens to be about
business but that's just what i think
are some of you still convinced that
robert is a douchebag comment that down
below
also drop a like if you think that
robert is truly a chill dude and of
course consider joining our discord
community to suggest your video ideas
and consider subscribing and see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm haruhi and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you